[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the columnist
at the eye newspaper ian dunt and anita
boten a broadcaster and former
conservative special advisor both with
us from now until just before midnight
welcome to both of you so let's take a
look shall we at the front pages this
week's rail strikes featuring on the
front page of the financial times with
the headline rail union resists as
bosses offer 3 pay rise for 2 000 job
cuts
while the yorkshire post focuses on
businesses fears over the impact on
trade caused by the national strikes the
headline reading retailers and pubs in
plitu sought out rail issues
the sun labels this week's rail strikes
and threatened strikes by teachers the
start of a class war
the eye looks at the government's
proposed laws to limit future strikes
saying they won't fix the crisis
they think it's all uber it is now reads
the daily star which reports that mps
were told to avoid today's travel chaos
by claiming taxi trips and hotel stays
back on expenses
tory bill accused of fatally weakening
human rights after a strasbourg judge
blocked the deportation of asylum
seekers to rwanda that story is on the
front page of the guardian
the telegraph's front story is on the
inflation link double digit increases to
go ahead to state pension and benefits
despite the government telling workers
to accept a real terms pay cut
gold age pensions a simple headline from
the metro on that same story
well a reminder by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen right now you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us so let's
return to our guest then columnist at
the i ian dunt and anita botan
broadcaster and former conservative
special adviser um we'll certainly come
onto those figures on pensions in just a
moment um but first of all ian your
assessment assessment of today
the rail strike the impact and what
happens next
well what does that say you know i mean
it's always a failure like if you get to
the point where there's a strike
everyone has failed management has
failed the unions have failed in this
case also the government has failed
because despite its repeated claims that
it can't go anywhere near the
negotiating table it is of course
the decisions are contingent on the
decisions it makes the controls the kind
of funding you're looking for national
rail it needs to be there and yet it's
done nothing to help the situation and
in fact has spent most of the last two
weeks as far as i can tell
making social media
memes about kia stamina somehow being
responsible for the strike so it seems
to be sort of this quite unseemly way
almost enthusiastic about the strikes
let alone being able to do anything to
help
there's very little sign at the moment
that it's going to be any better for the
rest of the week and like i say that is
a failure in pretty much every direction
you can consider
well indeed so and um you know the
impact being lessened or cushioned by
you know everybody's experiences during
the pandemic um working from home where
they can you know does that drag the
strike out does that mean
mean that the real action by the union
um is neutered in any way does it have
any impact at all anita
well i would say that i'm struck by the
fact that normally the papers following
a strike day would have pictures of sort
of
empty london and and old people kind of
enormous cues of people on for buses and
that kind of thing but we've seen i
can't see any of that on the front pages
so it might be an indication that
obviously office workers who can often
work from home and are choosing to have
a hybrid model mostly in um in in
business that we're actually seeing that
reflected through in response to days
like today but can i just respond to
some of what ian was saying about the
government's role in this i do sort of
wonder when people say well the
government needs to do more that
essentially means the government needs
to put some money on the table
and it's clear from the r t's
expectations which seem to be sort of
around seven percent and and what bosses
are being offered which is around three
percent as reported in the ft that
that's quite a big kind of golf and the
role that um the government would play
would basically be in funding and it
feels to me as we've just been talking
about the kind of hybrid working that
the ways in which we use the rail
service in general are going to change
and that really has to be engaged with
and it's i'm not i'm not convinced i'm
not entirely sure what people mean when
they say the government needs to do more
because because that feels to me like it
just means the government needs to give
um
just to provide additional funding to
either i know national rail etc to be
able to pay the workers more and prevent
the kind of redundancies that are going
to be needed to reshape um the rail
service for the future
yeah i mean this is this is not just
about payers there's been a lot of
coverage of of pay inflation matching
pay required but a lot of this is about
changing to working conditions the
sunday times talking about the closure
of all ticket offices which makes
consumers sit up and take notice as well
so how much is this about the need for
progress to increase um
you know effect
productivity i suppose is the best way
to describe it ian um and how much is
you know is the criticism of the union
being luddite effectively a genuine one
well their financial claim i think is
relatively modest it's still four points
below inflation inflation is about 11.
they're asking for seven percent i mean
i do think that's modest and i think
that's reasonable in its own terms when
you get into more dangerous territory is
with reluctance to adopt new practices
now we don't really know what the
details are of this but it's certainly
true the unions are quite reticent about
giving you information yes on ticket
offices but also on things that seem
more reasonable for instance like the
use of drones to assess tracks all of
that of course can have an impact on
members and sometimes unions are well
within their rights to complain about
them but looking at it from a sort of
broader societal point of view you think
well that's the kind of thing you could
do
so yes it can go both ways the financial
claim might be stronger some of the
working conditions claims might not be
so strong the trouble is it's not really
about the claims themselves it's about
how viable a negotiation you have if you
have a party that is key to the
decisions that are made and the
government is key to it we all
understand on any political analysis but
part of the reason the government wants
to be tough on this strike is because it
cannot afford to be seen to be soft on
it knowing that it's got teacher strikes
potentially coming down the tracks that
barristers are about to go on strikes
that there's probably going to be male
strikes that we're essentially in the
beginning of the summer of discontent so
on that basis if you've got a room with
two negotiating partners but in reality
there is a third partner who is not in
the room and pretending that it has
nothing to do with it while in fact
being completely contingent for the
outcome that doesn't seem like the most
conducive environment to get the result
that you want well certainly the sun
picks up on what you were saying about
the teaching unions uh saying the
national education union
has told number 10 it wants 12 pay rises
for its members by september at 12
um and we move on if we if you don't
mind to the metro which is talking about
a double-digit increase
in pensions
for older people retirees set to see
double-digit payments increases next
year as the state pension will be
determined based on september's cpi
inflation now is it difficult for the
government to defend do you think that
pensioners will get that much money when
still trying to draw a halt on pay
increases for for example public sector
workers anita
i think it's always been really tricky
the balancing act that the government
has to strike between pensioners and
those of working age i mean one of the
elements of this of course is um first
of all there is a commitment that was
suspended during coverage
of an increase of two and a half percent
rpi or cpi i believe um but
it feels to me like the difference for
most pensioners is that they don't
usually have other ways of raising
making more money um they they can't
work longer hours and get more pension
right um and so the government's always
had a slightly a sticky situation
particularly because pension equality
was for instance such a huge factor in
the sort of late uh the late sort of
2000s and that i think is is a kind of
element of the the conservative
government's commitment so much to um
ensuring that the pensioners do not give
and they don't have revenue they don't
they don't make money and they don't
have jobs and have income that their
living standards do not fall too far
behind but it's certainly not a um a
comfortable thing for the government at
the moment given it's trying so hard to
stop the inflation tiger from running
too far away
quick one from yoni on this as well ian
i think the last pension increase was
3.1 which came in april this year this
was after the pension triple lot was
suspended during the pandemic benefits
will also go up as well the telegraph
suggesting this will cost the taxpayer
as much as 20 billion pounds the
question now can it still hold the line
on fiscal discipline for the working age
population what do you reckon
no i mean the argument's completely
inconsistent i mean if you're sat there
saying that people going out to work are
going to have to suffer the pain but
pensioners people on benefits are not
that doesn't make sense the right
argument is actually this is correct
that we see pensions rise that we see
benefits rise you have to protect people
while inflation takes place and that
will itself have an inflationary effect
there's no point pretending otherwise it
will contribute to inflation but that's
not all that inflation is we know that
it's coming from external shocks as well
for instance energy prices as a result
of ukraine and various other factors
connected with covid this is the kind of
pain that inflation involves the one
thing you can do as a government is try
to protect people while it is there and
minimize the extent to which that has an
impact but there's no possible coherent
consistent argument that says that
there's a moral distinction between
those cases and the cases that we're
talking about which are affected by the
strike well i think we get the next
inflation update don't we tomorrow
morning so we'll certainly keep an eye
on that both of you stay there lots more
still to come including the front page
of the guardian uh torrey bill accused
of fatally weakening human rights this
after a strasbourg judge blocked the
deportation of asylum seekers to rwanda
we'll discuss that next
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview uh with me now the
columnist at the eye newspaper ian dunde
and anita boutain broadcaster and former
conservative special advisor welcome
back to both of you anita let's head to
the guardian this idea that a bill of
rights will be published tell us more
and how it fits in with the the
so-called rwanda plane that we remember
so well
well the interesting thing is that this
has been a conversation and certainly um
the
justice secretary dominick rob has been
a strong advocate of reforming the um
european um the human rights act which
was introduced in 1998 and enshrined um
the european convention on human rights
which is nothing to do with the eu's i'm
sure you'll read as well no
um but it was actually something that
came out of the second world war and is
really about enshrining universal rights
across um europe to ensure that people's
um rights to for instance the most
controversial one family life are
protected and the idea behind um the
british bill of rights is to basically
in stop in in the probably in the words
of dominic rob the kind of elastic
approach that that some might argue the
courts have taken to implementing the
european convention on human rights um
and have something that that feels more
i guess stripped back um i've got to say
as a conservative i struggle to get
particularly exercised about the
european convention on human rights in
in the negative sense of the word um but
but in any case um the the government is
pushing ahead with what's been in
manifestos um in years past and
certainly in 2019 to bring this um bill
of rights to um to the floor of the
house and get it straight through
parliament and and part of that
conversation is very wrapped up in the
incident from last week which your
viewers will recall um where the
european convention on human rights was
a decisive factor in the decision for
many people who were on board of that
rwandan flight not to be allowed to take
off essentially the argument that the
courts made that was successfully made
to the courts was that some permanent
possible damage might be done if people
were removed before there was an
opportunity for a full judicial review
to take place of the government's policy
yes certainly some stories were
exercised weren't they that uh
out of ours judge in europe decided the
fate of that plane um a short minute uh
daily telegraph story which is that the
uh the the uk pm will urge france and
germany to strengthen their support for
ukraine in
so he should um
it's
this constant bafflement about the kind
of rhetoric that comes from schultz and
from macron it's kind of mercurial
requires decoding macron's but perpetual
attempts to suggest that in some way uh
putin must not be humiliated there's
lots of the actions are good i mean
there's been an underestimation of the
kind of um export armed exports that
germany's been sending over but in terms
of the rhetoric it's really really quite
mercurial and it's about time that they
firmed it up so no anyone that can put
pressure on them to try and fix their
line would be very welcome indeed ian
dunde anita botang thanks both very much
indeed